hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over my favorite trap
in the ponziani opening panziani starts
out with
e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6
and then pawn two c3 this is the
ponziani preparing for d4
this pawn on c3 really really just
another pawn to support
this central push from white trying to
control that center of the board
knight to f6 pretty common from black
here and then d4 now black has
a lot of options here but we're going to
be specifically looking at
if the knight takes here on e4 this is a
pawn that's unprotected makes a lot of
sense for black to go ahead and take
that it's not really a terrible move
here
but white's just going to keep pushing
up the board here this pawn on e5 it's
only protected by the knight on c6 so
you always want to attack
pieces that are defending other squares
and this e5 square we want to be taking
with our knight here
so attacking this knight and there's not
a lot of great squares for this knight
to go to
if it wants to come back to b8 well now
blacks move
the knight here and then back so really
down
in tempo there so that's not something
you're going to see too often a5
is really a terrible move because after
b4 then the knight's going to fall
there's no squares that it can go to
safely and so really you're going to be
looking at knight to e7 but this
really blocks off a lot of the squares
that black wants to go to get the dark
square bishop involved into the game
get the queen involved into the game and
now white can just take here on e5
and now black really needs to move this
knight because
if they try to play something like d6
which opens up for the light square
bishop
attacking the knight this is going to be
a mistake because bishop two
b5 check pawn two c6 there's capture
here
knight takes here on c6 attacking the
queen queen comes out let's say to b6
but then knight to d4 this is a
discovered check
here from this bishop and this is in a
pretty tough spot you could see either
the king move here to
d8 and then white castles on the king
side
white is up in material black's king is
over here
it can't castle it's going to be
attacked the rest of the game
even if the bishop just comes here to d7
hey just go ahead and exchange right
here
same concept as before white should have
a pretty
good game from here so you're usually
not going to see
the pawn come to d6 because that would
be a mistake many times you'll just see
knight 2 g6 and this is where we're
going to lay
our trap because the knight comes here
to a logical square
if the knight takes it hey it's defended
by both of these pawns this opens up for
the queen and the bishop to get involved
into the game
but now we're going to be playing and
setting our trap and that is
bishop to d3
now from black's standpoint it may look
like white's just trying to
exchange some minor pieces it already is
kind of an awkward opening right away
so they may say yeah you know queen to
e7 and then
if you want to go ahead and take our
knight here on e4 we'll go in exchange
take our knight here or
if we want to take with our our queen
you know they have some options both
sides are equal in material
everything is good so many times if
that's what black thinks they may look
for another option
and so they may find the move which
isn't hard to find here
because anytime a knight on e4 or g4
arrives then many times they're looking
for the move knight takes on f2 and they
may see that okay
they take a pawn here and after the king
captures then
knight takes on e5 black is up upon a
material and this king is completely
exposed black can attack this the rest
of the game
it's going to be very difficult for
white to continue but that's exactly
what we want
black to do take this pawn here on f2
and feel really good about themselves
because we're going to be taking
with our bishop here on g6 now in this
position they should just really take
our bishop i mean they could also
if they wanted to get their bishop
involved maybe bishop here to c5 is a
reasonable move
but they may look at this and say what
is going on here are you just going to
give me
your queen absolutely we're just going
to give you
our queen because after knight takes
here on
d1 again they have fallen for the trap
we can just play bishop takes here on f7
check king comes to e7 we play
bishop to g5 and now it's time to get
more and more material involved into the
action because we are not done with our
attack
quite yet king comes here to d6
and we play knight two c4 and you can
see
all these squares are off limits can't
come
to e7 because of the bishop can't come
to e6 because of the pawn in the bishop
can't come here to e5
because of the knight here can't take
this pawn on
d5 because of the bishop can't come to
c6 because the pawn it has to come here
to
c5 now white can play the move knight to
a3 yes you can go ahead and take the
queen if you want to
you're gonna win the game in this
situation but you can also play knight
to a3
and the reason you can do that is you're
still going to win
the queen like there's no way for them
to protect themselves like they can't
just take
with their queen here on g5 because then
we just play pawn to
b4 checkmate they can't just take that
pawn if they may look and say okay well
pawn to b4 is going to be checkmate
let's just go ahead and take with their
knight here on
a b2 well then we just play bishop to e3
and that's checkmate they could also
look at that pawn to b4 and say okay
well let's try
pawn two a5 and then we just take their
queen here on
d8 we're preparing to just take pawn
here on
c7 to start gobbling up material here
things are not looking
any better as their king is completely
in the center of the board
this knight here on c4 is protected by
this knight
this pawn still protected by the bishop
up here on f7
we can easily start to gobble up
material come here
to b6 that square is defended by our
knights here
there's just no real good squares for
them to come to even if they want to
gobble up some other material let's say
knight takes here on
uh c3 yes we could take that knight but
another
another position where you could say
okay if i don't find another great move
well i can just go ahead and take this
queen here on d8 and you're going to be
completely
fine so that is the flagship trap
what's what i really like about this is
even if they don't take the trap because
sometimes you you try to lay a trap and
your opponent doesn't take and you're
like oh my goodness
i'm in a really terrible spot what's
nice about this is
even if they don't take it you're not in
a terrible spot like they could easily
not take here on f2 and they just take
on e5 and then you take their
knights here on e4 maybe they play
bishop to c5
you castle on the king side you're equal
immaterial
you have nice central pawn here
your bishop's involvement into the game
you've already castled on the king's
side so
this is why this is my favorite trap in
the ponziani because
i i think it will come up more than you
may think and
you're still in a really good position
even if they don't fall
for the trap so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video
uh hopefully you want to see more trap
videos because i do have some
really good ones i want to share with
you guys so let me know in the comments
below
if you want to see more of these or if
there's other type of videos like
openings i know a lot of people like to
see those as well
but let me know what you guys think
thanks again so much for watching i'll
see you guys
in the next video
you